Now I'd like to introduce today's
speakers from right to left.
Kara Scoggin, who you will be hearing from
later today, is the senior communications
manager of Stanford Center for
Professional Development, responsible for
advancing student engagement inside and
outside of Stanford.
Today's featured presenters
are Kenji Hakuta, Jeff Zwiers and
Sara Rutherford-Quach.
Sara, a former bilingual elementary
teacher has more than 13 years of
experience working with the linguistically
diverse students and their teachers, and
has conducted extensive research
on instructional practices for
English learners.
Sara was previously awarded
a National Academy of
Education Spencer Foundation
Dissertation Fellowship for
her work on the role of silence and
speech in an elementary classroom
serving language minority students.
Her areas of interests include classroom
discourse and interaction analysis,
language, culture, and instruction in
multilingual and multicultural educational
environments, institutional policy and
curricular change and educational equity.
Sara has been involved with the design and
teaching of more than 20
MOOC offerings since 2013.
And she has also directed the development
of many learning modules with the smarter
balance assessment consortium and
the ELPA21 consortium.
Jeff has worked for more than 15
years as a professional developer and
instructional mentor in
urban school settings,
emphasizing the development of literacy,
thinking and academic language for
linguistically and
culturally diverse students.
He has published books and articles on
reading, thinking, and academic language.
His most recent book is
Academic Conversations: Classroom Talk
that Fosters Critical Thinking and
Content Understandings.
His current work at the Center to
Support Excellence in Teaching focuses
on developing teachers, core practices for
teaching academic language,
comprehension of complex text, and oral
communication skills across subject areas.
And Kenji Hakuta is active
in education policy.
He has testified to Congress and courts
on language policy, the education of
language minority students, affirmative
action in higher education, and
improvement of quality
in educational research.
Kenji is an elected member of
the National Academy of Education,
a fellow of the American Educational
Research Association, and
a fellow of the American Association for
the Advancement of Science, recognized for
his accomplishments in linguistics and
language sciences.
He has served on the board
of various organizations,
including the Educational Testing Service,
the Spencer Foundation and
the New Teacher Center.
Now I'd like to turn
the floor over to Kenji.
>> Good morning everyone, and
thank you for taking the time and
on a nice summer day to join us today for
our presentation about
the course that we'll be offering,
Rich Talk = Rich Learning.
And I'm pleased to be opening up
this presentation with my colleagues
Jeff Zwiers and Sara Rutherford-Quach.
To begin,
I'd like to view a video of a classroom,
an ELD or an English language development.
They're in parts of countries called
English as second language or
it was the new language class,
of fourth grade students who are having
conversation having just read
The True Story of The Three Little Pigs.
And after reading,
students are discussing as a prompt
whether the wolf was guilty or not.
And so I'm going to play this video.
>> The big bad wolf is not guilty
because he was baking a cake for
his grandma and
he had a really bad cold and
he blowed the house down by
accident because he had a cold.
>> So what you're saying is the big
bad wolf isn't guilty because he was
trying to make a cake for his grandma and
he had a really bad cold and
he needed sugar to go get.
And he accidentally sneezed down
the houses because he had a cold.
>> Yes, that was what I was saying.
>> The big bad wolf is guilty because
what if he sneezed on purpose?
And what if the pigs weren't able
to sneeze it down, I mean to sneeze
down the house, and he made up his own
story, and he made it all planned?
>> So what you're saying is that
the Big Bad Wolf is guilty,
because he might have
sneezed on purpose and
blown the house down on purpose and
the pigs are [INAUDIBLE]
>> What I mean is he's doing
it on purpose because I
think he made his own
story to make all the big
bad things align.
>> So, you're saying is that
he made up the whole story.
So, he doesn't want to go to jail.
>> So now just having watched that video,
let's just talk about why
the role of rich talk and
rich learning in this conversation
that we just observed.
And then ask really questions
about the fundamental
role of language in
classroom as students learn.
One is that students
are wired to interact, that
really the role that language plays
is in facilitating interaction.
But what you really saw in the video
was two students who were really
interacting about the prompt of whether
the big bad wolf was guilty or not.
Why or why not?
Sharing ideas and so forth.
And it's something that you hope
to see in a lot of classrooms and
that's why we showed it and
this is really the purpose of course
is to try to promote
instructional strategies for
supporting students being able to
engage and interact in this way.
And one of the things we hope
to show you in the video, and
those of you who saw it probably witnessed
this, might think back to the video and
saying okay, this is really what
language is about for kids.
It's not about repeating vocabulary words.
It's not about struggling to find
the correct tense on a verb.
It really is about interacting and
engaging with others.
Another question you might ask of this
video, if you had to think about this was,
were there opportunities for
students to think on their feet?
A conversation is not about scripted,
going back and forth, reading sentences.
But it really is about
spontaneous listening to others,
thinking about what the other said, and
trying to formulate your own ideas
relative to what the other person said.
And it is a live animal so to speak.
It's also an opportunity
to try out ideas that,
a conversation is wonderful
because not everything
is transcribed, and
you're not held accountable for
it except during the immediate moment.
So it's a great time to try out ideas.
What you think about this?
Or this is what I'm thinking,
and so forth.
So that spontaneity and
trying out ideas is
another important
component of conversations.
Another is around clarifying ideas and
sometimes others will help you,
because they will say not quite
sure what you said there.
Or is this what you mean?
And that allows you to
sharpen your own thinking by just by
sort of putting the words out there.
This conversation is also another way in
which you can try to support your ideas.
Ideas are complex.
They are, whether you're guilty or
not, is a complex
idea and you may find multiple
ways to try to support that.
And so these are the sorts of things that,
at least those of you who saw the video,
probably saw that
the students struggling with.
A lot of this is around language being,
it's a biological thing.
It's something that's alive,
it's spontaneous, it's creative.
And these are the kind of
elements of conversation.
I'm going to ask Sara and
Jeff if you might want to comment on some
of what you might have seen in the video.
>> This is Jeff.
I'd like to zoom in on clarifying ideas..
What you will see or
what you might have seen in
the video is a lot of paraphrasing.
And paraphrasing, even though it seems
like it's just repeating things,
it's a powerful way for kids to both get
feedback on how clear their ideas are.
But it's also a way to build
language as I clarify your idea,
or as I paraphrase your idea.
I'm practicing with the language.
So it's an authentic way
to practice language
when you're in a conversation with others.
>> Sara, you want to add anything that.
They're having a conversation
here by the way.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
it really is about how we develop
our thinking and develop language.
>> [LAUGH] One thing I wanna add, and
this kind of encompasses all of this.
Is that all of these things or
even conversation moves or
are trying to get students to paraphrase.
You can try these things out but
at the heart of it,
if your classroom does not have a culture
where it's okay to make mistakes and
it's okay to say things that aren't
exactly the polished final results,
then a lot of these
things will be difficult.
And so one of the things that we're
trying to do in this course and
in this webinar is that we're trying
to build a culture of conversation.
But also a culture where
Knowledge is something that's
generated throughout time.
And you don't just ask and
answer questions.
You ask a question and
they come back with an answer.
So the idea of conversations is that
they're building towards an answer, and
they're working on it.
And so that's one of the things
that if that's not there,
then all of these different
points are hard to do.
So I want to make sure that we mention
that as we move on because that's
kind of at the heart of what this building
a culture of classroom conversation is.
>> Great, thank you.
And this really, the idea of conversation
as being the way in which content,
thinking and language come together.
Think of them as sort of a macrame or
blending together of these is really what
we were hoping to promote in this course.
And the context for this work,
and Sara and Jeff and I and
others on our team have been working for
the last three years now.
Offering free online courses, MOOCs,
trying to experimenting
around with this idea.
And part of what motivated us to do
this work was because of the shifts in
standards that were going
on around the country.
Some of them called our call the Common
Core in English, language arts and math.
Many states call them college and
career ready standards.
But all of them are are really
related standards in that
they're really trying to promote deeper,
more rigorous,
uses of language in the course of
learning English language arts skills,
as well as mathematical skills.
And states that have
adopted the next generation
science standards or
similar variations on science.
A lot of them require
collaborative language.
They require argumentation.
They require engagement and
explanation of one's reasoning
around complex texts and so forth.
And so that's what we're trying to gain.
And a lot of the shifts
really require a move from
thinking about the language
being used as an individual
accumulating of the right answers,
"paying" for points, or playing school.
And rather the actual
engagement with language in
the course of collaborative
conversations that are happening.
And so what we want to see is
less of this kind of formulaic
repetitive kinds of uses of language and
more around collaborating,
understanding, building, using and
communicating whole ideas.
That these new requirements for
how we should really think about
engaging students in rigorous content
that's supported by the shift
in the standards towards
college career ready standards,
really requires this kind of more organic,
more rich,
collaborative, dyadic or
group conversational uses of language.
So I'm going to now
shift this over to Jeff,
who is going to elaborate further on
what we'll be doing in this course.
>> Jeff here, and I want to start off with
looking at, there are a lot of fake or
inauthentic conversations out there.
And here's a nice quotation
by a philosopher I believe.
The more genuine conversation is,
the less it's conduct lies within
the will of either partner...
A conversation has a spirit of its own,
and
the language in which it is conducted
bears its own truth within it.
That is, it allows something him
to emerge which henceforth exists.
So in a conversation,
two people bring their ideas.
But they're not just memorized, and
they're not just one person sharing their
idea with the other, they build something.
And so that's what we're trying
to get out in the classroom,
is how can students work with each other
to construct ideas in conversation.
And, but as Sara eluded to earlier,
we also have to
foster some conversational
mindsets in our students.
It's not just teachers doing things.
It's also students need to unlearn
a few things, and need to learn that
conversation and working with others can
be a powerful way to learn many things.
And so
here's a semi-humorous slide although,
there's a non humorous element to it.
If you look at it, what we'd like you to
just each time with a topic is introduced,
for example, today will begin our
unit on the American Revolution.
Every student thinks, and this is where
you can start laughing if you want,
but I can't wait to share my ideas and
hear those of others.
You know you're probably thinking how many
students actually think that and then.
I'll learn and
remember this better by talking about it.
Now there might be a certain
few kids that might think that,
because they like to talk, but
we're not as concerned about those kids.
I like it when partners push me to think,
build and clarify.
Yeah, and I'm not sure how many kids I
know, and I'm open to changing my mind and
learning new ideas from others.
And so these types of mindsets make
up the culture of conversation, and the
culture of learning through conversation.
Actually if you look at this,
I sometimes wonder how many adults
in different settings have these.
And what we want,
we want our students to grow up into
adults that also have these
types of mindsets right.
That they're not just individual competing
with others and just learning on my own.
And so that's one of the things that
we try to emphasize in our work.
Let's look at, another area important
area is looking at the prompts,
this is come up in our ongoing
research that we do with
teachers related to our online courses and
other work.
And we've found that there's a big
struggle to come up with effective
prompts, and so a couple things
that we'll cover it briefly here.
One is having a purpose for conversing.
A lot of kids and adults don't
often know why they're talking,
don't have a solid purpose or direction.
There's also, the prompt should require
thinking and doing something with ideas.
So, not just regurgitating, but
actually transforming ideas in some way,
transforming, fortifying,
that kind of thing.
And then finally, they should encourage
students to share novel ideas and
learn from one another,
like we said earlier it's not just
I'm sharing my wisdom with you, and you're
just agreeing and nodding your head.
So there's a building, there's I bring
some materials to the conversation,
you bring some materials, and
then we both construct something that
we couldn't have done on our own.
And now let's look at some sample
prompts and we'll see how these do.
What's the most important theme for
fourth graders in this story?
Does that hit all the boxes here?
If there is a purpose,
I might have a different idea than you.
They require thinking, definitely this
type of interpretive thinking, and
each kid might have a novel idea,
even if they have the same theme in their
mind as they come to the conversation.
There's different reasons for it and
different ways of expressing it.
Often there's going to
be different evidence.
How about.
What conclusions can we make about animal
adaptations based on this evidence?
So it's a science prompt.
Does it have a purpose?
Yes.
Does it require thinking?
Does it encourage students
to share novel ideas?
In most cases, students will be
able to share novel ideas and
have them synthesize and combine together.
How about, collaborate to create
a real world word problem
that requires both adding and
subtracting of fractions.
So this also, there's a purpose,
they're constructing something,
it requires thinking, because they have to
apply some of the thinking that they've
been doing in other
probably similar problems.
And it encourages them to share some novel
ideas about what kind of problem we're
gonna create together.
And then finally,
another example, would be.
Was Christopher Columbus a hero or not?
And this is a common topic
in a lot of schools and
what I like to do is,
does this does it have a purpose?
Yes.
Does it require thinking?
And does it encourage students
to share novel ideas?
And what I'd like to do is
look at again look at these.
Let's see if the prompt actually
works with this little snippet of
a conversation.
Okay, so it's the same prompt.
I don't think Columbus was a hero.
Why not?
Cuz he hurt them and
made them to be slaves.
But he helped Spain get rich and
he found America.
So?
He hurt them.
Heroes don't hurt or make slaves.
Maybe.
But he was brave to keep sailing.
He had maps.
And he met a Portuguese guy.
That guy should be famous, not Columbus.
Okay, so did the prompt work?
And that's one of the questions
that we wanna continue to ask as we
work with conversations.
The conversations are extremely messy,
especially paired conversations.
You have 15 to whatever conversations
going on simultaneously.
It's a messy business.
It's loud and you can only listen to a few
at a time when you're in the classroom.
So, we have to really
get our prompts right.
And, that's one of the things
that we try to work on.
How can we come up with prompts?
Of course, there's a lot that
leads into that prompt as well.
There's a lot of things that kids need
to learn, like about the Portuguese guy.
But, we want kids to learn things and
then be able to share them in these
conversations, because a lot, it's almost
like a foundry where they're adding
things and they're coming up with new
things, or adding their own ideas and
then they're coming up with new things
in this foundry of conversation.
And I think, I'm gonna pass it on now.
We're gonna dig in even more deeply to
look at the formative assessment of
conversation.
I'm gonna pass it on to Sara now.
>> Okay, so this is a great segue because
we talked a little bit about prompts and
how forming a thoughtful prompts that
engenders conversation is really
important.
And not necessarily
a problem that just ask for
a single answer or a series of answers.
But that is important,
but only when paired with
a formative assessment of conversations.
And what we mean by that
is basically listening to
current student conversations.
Where your students are right now.
Or if it's a summer,
where other students are right now.
And then thinking about,
where you'd like them to be?
So a lot of you and when I was
the teacher I did turn in talks, right?
So I taught kindergarten and
first grade, and
I would have the kids turn to each other
and talk all the time, probably two or
three, four times on the carpet
while we were there.
But I didn't necessarily know
what they were all saying and
I couldn't, because there was 1 of me and
20 different kids, so there's 10 different
conversations going on, or I hope there's
10 different conversations going on.
So one thing that we really advocate for
is really focusing in on one or
two conversation, recording those
conversations and listening to
the recording and transcribing it so that
you can really tell what kids are saying.
So one thing we've learned from that
is a lot of times when we think
kids are saying a certain thing we think
students are conversing in a certain way
even when we're hearing them,
when we record the conversations and
we listen back to it,
that's not actually what happened.
And so actually listening and paying
very close attention to where students
are currently in their conversations
is really important, so
that you can get them to where
you would like them to be.
And we've created a tool.
If I can get this called the conversation
analysis tool that will help you formally
assess the conversation.
And this, as you see here on the fly,
this dimension zero, dimension one and
dimension two.
So I'm going to talk about dimension
one and dimension two first,
because these are the first two
dimensions that we've created.
So there's only two two
main dimensions here.
And we've kept it simple on
purpose because we want you to be
very focused on these things, and
we found them to be the most important and
building up a conversation.
The dimension one, turns build and
previous turns to build up an idea, and
by turn,
we mean when one person is talking.
So if Jeff and
I were having a conversation right now,
I would say hey, Jeff, how are you doing?
And that would be one turn,
and Jeff may answer me and
then that would be a second turn.
Now it's his turn.
So dimension one, we say Jeff and
I turn we build on each other, so
that we build up an idea over time.
So say our question was
a prompt that we had before.
It was Columbus a hero.
And so, I may say I don't
think Columbus is a hero,
and just may ask me why
do you not think that?
But it's not unless it's over time
to build up an idea about whether
Columbus is or is not a hero.
And then so that's the first one,
build up on turns build on each others
build up an idea, and then dimension two,
it turns focus on the content or
skills related to the lessons objectives.
So this is not anything new for educators.
Basically, we want to make sure
that students are actually talking
about the problems.
They're addressing the prompts.
As an early elementary teacher,
this would happen a lot,
we'd ask a question about so
what did Tommy do at that birthday party?
And the kids would go off, and I had a
birthday party last week, and I got cake.
And so, that's the sort of you know
in the realm of birthday parties, but
it's not actually addressing
the prompt the dimension two is,
are they actually addressing that?
And one thing that the teachers that
we worked with in the past have
found is when we're focusing on that,
a lot of times we have a ha ha's, and
realize sometimes that our problems that
we're crafting don't necessarily match
the objectives that we had.
So by looking very closely at this,
you can see where is the match between
the prompt and the objective and
the students conversation.
That's a dimension one and dimension two.
So, dimension zero is students
take appropriate turns.
Now, we added this dimension, this is
an optional dimension, but we added it in
here, after getting feedback from
specifically early elementary teachers,
kindergarten, first, second graders,
pre-K teachers who were saying
these dimensions are great, but
my students aren't there yet,
they're still practicing how to
actually take turns with each other.
And so, let's say, and
I have two young children, so
I can see this in practice as well.
So, I take a turn, you take a turn.
And so, a lot of times, particular
when you're asking them to address
particular academic subject for
a prompt, kids may talk over each other,
one person may talk and do all of the
talking, the other person doesn't respond.
So, dimensions here are basically looks
at whether or not they're taking turns.
So this is a conversation analysis tool.
We are going to keep that in mind now,
we're just going to focus on,
we'll do all three dimensions, dimension
zero, dimension one and dimension two.
And let's take a look at
some sample conversations.
And I'm going to ask my colleagues,
Jeff and Kenji, to join me here,
where we're going to look
at two conversations,
one from a fourth grade class, and
one from, I think a first grade class.
This is the first grade one first.
And we're going to go back and we're
going to look at the conversation, and
then we're going to try
to formatively assess it,
based on the conversation
now with this tool.
Just to give you an idea of how it works.
So maybe Jeff,
can you read this conversation with me?
I'll be A.
And we don't know the prompt.
Do you know the prompt?
>> I think it should, the main character,
but share the bread at the end or not?
>> Okay, and
this is about the little red hen, right?
Okay.
>> And just before that,
a quick little quiz.
What were the dimensions again
of the conversation else?
Because as you as we read this,
probably not in front of you right now,
what was the mention zero?
Can you remember?
>> Can I answer, Jeff?
>> Yeah.
>> [LAUGH] Dimensions zero is
are the students taking turns.
>> Mention one.
>> Kenji.
>> Did they build on each other?
>> To build up an idea.
>> Built up an idea.
>> Did the turns address the lessons
objective, and that it's not written there
in the prompt, but
basically the objectives of the content.
>> Focus on the content, okay, good.
[CROSSTALK]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay, and this is a little red hen.
Okay.
I think she not share it.
>> Why?
>> Because the other animals not work.
They're just lazy.
>> Yeah.
I don't think to share, too.
>> Why?
>> Like my dad.
He work for money.
Not work, no money.
Yeah, no [FOREIGN]
>> Not fair,
but teacher said it's good to share.
>> I share when they help.
Maybe I paint the school,
it's my money, you know?
>> No.
Maybe if [FOREIGN] like they're
sick, maybe.
But this story, animals are lazy.
>> It's good to share, but
not all the time, not with the lazy.
Okay, so you can see.
>> They did take turns.
>> So, and we didn't show you
basically their different categories.
If there's no evidence of taking turns,
then you might say there's no evidence,
if there's strong evidence, and
you'd say there's strong evidence.
A couple things that we want to
stress before we actually look at
dimensions one and two, the conversation
on the stool is not a grading tool.
It's not a summative tool,
it's basically for formative assessment.
It's to help you see where your
students are so you can get there, but
it's not for students to get a grade,
it's for you and for
them to figure out how you
can help them move forward.
The second thing is the conversation
else this tool is for two people.
It's not for one person.
So I'm not going to go to student A and
say student A did a great job
of taking turns, they did great.
It's them together as a unit, and
that's because conversations can
help happen with one person.
And we also want to, we try to, to really,
really advocate for
not using this as a grading tool, and
it's harder to use it as a grading tool if
you're using two people rather than one.
Okay, that's my spiel, so you think
Kenji that they were taking turns?
>> Well, they did they turns.
>> Yep, okay, what about to mention one?
Dimension one is turned to build on
each other in order to build up an idea.
>> I would agree that they
weren't just popcorn.
The ideas around and in terms,
definitely connected to one another.
And an idea was built up at the end, I
think the idea of not sharing with lazies.
>> [LAUGH] Let's remember this
is a little red hen, right?
And so, if we had the tool in front of us
that had the more detailed dimensions, and
the different categories of
each dimension, no evidence
all the way up to strong evidence,
this may be somewhere in between.
Strong evidence and the category
that's a little bit below that.
Yeah.
And one more thing is that these are first
graders who are bilingual students who
their English is starting to emerge.
And one thing we want to point out is you
can see there's a lot of quote unquote
grammatical errors in this.
That does not matter for
the conversation analysis tool.
We are not measuring whether they have
again, quote and quote, perfect English.
Because what we're measuring is whether or
not they're building a each other and
building up a conversation and
building up knowledge together,
which doesn't require,
total acquisition of the language.
And this is the fourth
grade science lesson.
And Jeff, can you give us a prompt for
this one?
>> Yeah, it's how do animals evolve.
>> There you go, it's right there, okay.
>> Terms on the board.
>> Okay, so I'll be Elia.
>> Okay.
>> So how do animals evolve?
>> To live.
>> What's an example?
>> Sharks.
>> [LAUGH] What's another example?
>> Turtles.
>> Giraffes.
They got long necks.
>> Why?
>> To reach up into trees.
>> Okay, let's write these down.
So let's do a quick assessment of that.
How about dimension zero
were they taking turns?
>> Yeah.
>> Sort of.
>> Right it goes student A,
student B, Elia and then Alex.
>> Yeah, there definitely is the turn
taking, and then you get to dimension one
then you start talking about well,
are they really building up something.
They are building on one another's ideas,
sort of.
But they're not really
building up anything yet.
>> Yep, I mean they're not
randomly saying things, right?
But they're not building
an up idea together.
They're more making a list.
>> There's a little potential at the end
with that they got long necks to reach up
in the trees, right?
>> [LAUGH] Yeah.
>> So they're kinda getting there,
and this is an important point.
Sometimes it does take a while in
a conversation, for kids to actually get
to as an adults, to actually get
to yeah we are building something.
There are some ideas we can talk about,
right?
So there is a little warm up.
>> In this conversation little bit
models what the teachers might be asking
the whole class.
A series of questions, and then answers,
rotating around the students.
>> And yeah, we do want students to become
more like teachers in some respects.
If you look at Alex's to live now
wouldn't enough for a teacher.
A teacher who was listening to that
answer, a teacher would say okay,
well let me explain what that means.
And also with the sharks example.
A teacher wouldn't say
what's another example,
a teacher would say you elaborate.
Please elaborate how sharks
answers its question.
So there would be more
pushing from the teacher,
which is what we want students to do.
We want students to be like little mini
teachers out in the classroom that elicit
lots more language out of students than
what normally happens between students.
>> Okay, so
dimension one as far building up.
So our consensus is that we don't really
feel like there's a lot of building up
here, a little bit of potential at the
bottom, but not a strong evidence of it.
What about dimension two, is do the turns
address the content or the objective?
So the prompt again was, so
how do the animals evolve?
>> I mean it's not way off base,
they have some examples.
In their head, I think they do have,
they're not explaining it,
which is what we want.
>> Exactly.
>> But
I think they’re definitely getting there.
So I would say wherever that
level would be some evidence.
>> In the middle, yeah, some evidence.
>> Lots to work with.
>> [LAUGH] So
another thing we want to point out is
that the syntax of these examples, the
fourth grade example, is perfect right?
The questions are articulated,
in a way that would be stereotypically
grammatically correct, but
that does not matter because this
actually shows more evidence.
The first grade example shows more
evidence of building on each other to
build up an idea and conversation
than the fourth grade example does.
So this is how this tool is a little
bit different than things that you
may have used in the past.
Okay so I think this is our last
slide before we open it up a bit.
And so as we move forward and
as you move forward for preparing for
formative assessment of conversations
in your classrooms, come this fall.
There are a few things that
you can do to get ready for
this, if you take on this challenge.
The first thing is look at
the big ideas in each unit to
draft conversation prompts.
I know one thing that I was guilty
of as it is a classroom teacher,
I would wait to get right in front of
the students to think about prompts and
then I would ask them to turn and talk,
and I would just pose a question.
But I wouldn't really
put a lot of time and
energy into developing those
prompts ahead of time.
So other times my on the on
the fly questions didn't actually
engender the type of
conversations I was looking for.
So that's one, and
then here's two and three.
Think about what you want to see.
So if you were asking
a question about Columbus,
what sort of conversations would you
want to see in an ideal situation?
And then write those down.
It actually helps for
you to envision what the conversations or
the model conversations would be.
And then I would say, when time comes,
share those with the students, too.
Number three is practice with
the conversation analysis tool.
So that's the tool that we
just demonstrated with.
It's called the conversation
analysis tool.
It has two required dimensions and
one optional dimension.
And you won't be able to practice with
your own students because they're
obviously you're not in school right
now unless you're in year around.
But we have sample conversations that
you can practice with until then.
And then four, write model
conversations that show features.
This is an extension of number two, right,
thinking about what you want to see and
then you actually write it down.
And number five, start assessing
the first month of school and
have students self- and peer-assess.
And so again,
this is start formatively assessing, or
start the process of formatively assessing
conversations during the first months of
school and
involve students in that process.
So look at model conversations together,
record their own conversations,
have the students listen
to their own conversations.
And then they can have an idea of
what you're looking for and so
they can move closer to that.
Okay, and then I'm wanna open up
to final thoughts from Jeff and
Kenji before we address any
questions that are lingering.
>> Well that was a lot in
a little compact space.
We hope that it has given you, and
we will probably answer some
questions here as well.
But we hope that it's given you,
I'd say some inspiration and
some interest in trying
some of these things out.
Because one of the things that we've
also encountered is, it takes time and
patience, and lots of trials to get
these things going in the classroom.
If you just try it once twice even for
a month or two,
it doesn't really get going
till maybe half a year.
Some teachers will say no, it took me
a year or two to actually understand
how to get kids conversing and
how to build their conversation skills.
So it's really,
the question often comes up is this
worth the time, is it worth the time?
Most people on this webinar
are probably interested in it enough to
think it's worth the time but
in a larger swath of district and schools,
we're still doing the kind of this
traditional memorize the stuff,
take a test, pay for
my points with my facts and that's it.
And there's a lot of the traditional and
so this
is a major overhaul as Kenji alluded to in
the beginning and so thinking about it,
we have to think about and
really listen in to kids conversations.
Valuing what they have to say,
valuing their voices but
also at the same time thinking how is
this useful for learning of content,
learning of language, learning of
thinking skills and social skills.
One of those things is often missing.
A lot of kids it's just the ability to
have good conversations with a wide
range of others.
So I'm hoping that some
of the stuff will come
out in the future as we work through this.
>> I'd like you to share that during
the past few years of doing this work,
we've heard from lots of districts
who have been using these tools, and
that there is tremendous variation
out there in how much the orientation
towards conversation as a form
of academic learning is sort of
integrated or becoming sort of
a district-wide as a culture.
And for some, you see it more in
certain subject areas than for others.
English language arts more than math.
Others you see more of it and so
there are these pockets of kind of
cultural changes for a culture of
conversation that's happening.
But I just want to acknowledge that
many of you will be in districts with,
in different kinds of settings.
The other thing I would like to share
is just that we kind of started this
workout thinking about supporting
English language learners.
But as we've done this work and
seen the responses to it, a lot
of the realization is that this really is,
you might think of English language
learners as being the tip of the iceberg
or the canary in the mine or whatever.
And these are students for
whom this kind of engagement with language
is necessary for English language
development but it's really a form
of learning for all students.
And so the uptake of our work is then
not just about teachers who would
consider themselves English language
learners but for all teachers
who think of themselves as teachers
primarily of core academic content.
>> Yep.
Okay, well thank you Kenji,
Jeff, and Sara.
This is Kara Scoggin now with the Stanford
Center for Professional Development and
while we take a moment to prepare for
the Q and A portion of today's Webinar,
we'd like to take a brief moment
to tell you about the Center.
The Stanford Center for Professional
Development makes it possible for today's
best and brightest professionals to
enroll in Stanford University courses and
programs while they
maintain their careers.
This of course helps you to continue your
education while advancing your career,
organization or
in this case your classroom.
Most curriculum is delivered entirely
online and opportunities to take
class at Stanford or at your work site
are also available through the center.
Basically it's your acces point to
the teaching and research at Stanford.
Starting this August,
a three week online course
taught by our presenters today Kenji,
Sara and Jeff just will be made available.
We're very excited about this.
Effective conversation in the classroom is
specifically designed to help you prepare
for the new school year.
A vital time for fostering a culture of
productive and respectful communication.
Enrollment for this course is open now and
can be found it at scpd.stanford.edu.
You may also be interested in and
in another course we have,
how to learn math for teachers.
This course is also available entirely
online and covers teaching strategies for
increasing student's math,
motivation and achievement,
and enrollment again can be
found at scpd.stanford.edu.
Now let's get started with our Q and
A portion.
We have some wonderful question
from our participants online,
the first one being how did students react
when they know they're being recorded?.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> I'm muted, sorry.
Okay, I'm not muted now, right?
Okay, so this is Sara and I was gonna say
it takes a little bit of time for students
to feel comfortable recorded but we've
done it in our classrooms for forever and
I would say two or three days of doing
this depending on a student's age and
they just act like nothing's happening.
We have usually typically
used audio recording and
in our previous courses
that's what we have, IRB or
research permission for audio recording.
There are also times where we use video
recording and we have a lot of video
examples of students that you could see
in this course if you sign up for it.
Video is a little bit more tricky as far
as students' reaction because they can
visually see it more but
they still get used to it over time.
If you start doing it when they're younger
I think it makes a big difference.
And then it's not up here but
I saw one that was kind of related
to it about is there any sort
of app or have you had students use their
phones to record and they send it to you?
Different educators have
done different things.
We actually have a colleague who's
working on an App that we could actually
all use together,
it's not completed yet but, hopefully
in the next year or two it will be.
But what most people have done now is
the teacher has either recorded using her
phone, if you have a smartphone,
it's very easy to do that.
Just place the recording down on
the table in between the students.
I haven't heard of the students
recording it and sending it to you, but
I don't think there's any reason why they
couldn't if they're older obviously.
I'm kind of old school and
I actually have a digital recorder
that I use a lot of the time.
I know some people have used iPads or
their actual computer.
The bigger you get the bulkier
here it is obviously.
But the most important thing
no matter what you use,
is that you actually
can hear both of them.
And so, if you have 20 conversations going
on in the room and you put the recorder
on your desk, you're not really gonna hear
any of those conversations very well.
So, you wanna it as close to
the students as you can get.
Anyone else wanna and anything?
>> Yeah, and more often than not
the students are more engaged in
conversing because there's a little
bit more accountability to it.
They're not freaked out.
They're not freaked out as much as of
the video and so we've had kids with their
phones and I actually call in and send
their files up to the teacher, name them.
And so there's different ways to
do that but I would say overall,
it's a good to get kids used to that and
recording it, even if you don't listen.
Which you can't listen to all of them.
It is a way of you might listen
to them and that's more so
even if you're not recorded at all and
two kids are in the corner talking
about the Friday night party.
>> Yeah.
>> So I would just say that,
as a quick answer.
>> I would just add one more
thing around this recording
of student conversation, is that working?
Around recording a student conversation,
which is that,
I know that many teachers around peer
observation of each other's teaching feel
a little uncomfortable sometimes sharing
sort of observations of teacher practice.
And that looking at each others
students language practice is,
really lowers the threshold for
collaboration.
That people feel much more comfortable
having their students being there.
It's their students
behavior that's looked at.
Even though it really is the teacher and
what the teacher does around good prompts
and so forth,
that really supports a good conversation.
But that this is a really good,
really good tool to embed within a teacher
collaboration community at school
>> Well,
that kind of leads us
into this next question.
It sounds like that's a great piece
of advice you're giving teachers.
But one of our participants is curious.
What advice would you give for high school
teachers who are trying to increase and or
improve the quantity and
quality of whole class conversations?
>> Whole class.
>> One thing that I would emphasize and
have emphasized is building
some of the skills.
The conversation skills that you
wanna see in paired conversations.
Just having built that into
the whole class conversations, and
having students take on some of the,
like I said before.
A little more of that teacher like role.
So, instead of,
when someone answers a question.
Always the teacher's saying,
can you support that from the text?
Pushing that out on the students and
saying.
Okay, what do we say next?
So really bring in the whole class kind
of habits of conversation out on to them.
Because what they've been used to
especially before high school and
that's a lot of years of school.
They've been used to the teacher
directing all things conversation.
And so changing that around and
saying, you know what?
You guys are gonna do more of
the direction of the conversation and
there's a few skills that you can work on,
and even as a whole class.
For example,
can you support that idea from the text?
Can you clarify that?
What do you mean by this?
Even those things that teachers usually do
are conversation skills that students can
build in a whole class setting.
In addition to that, another important
aspect is having a kind of clear prompt
and direction for the classroom
conversation, which often doesn't.
Sometimes it's just, okay I have
discussion down in my lesson plan and
that's it.
But if there isn't really
a firm direction that you have.
For okay, what are we gonna do with this
five minute class, whole class discussion?
You never know exactly
where you're gonna be.
You can't script everything.
You don't know exactly, but at least
you have at least a default direction,
because you can go all over the place.
Anybody else?
>> I think that's a great answer.
Excellent.
Well our next question is, are there
differences of what to listen for
in terms of analysis of conversations when
different disciplines ie., math, English,
science art, etc.?
Are there sources for good prompts for
distinct disciplines?
>> It's a good question.
>> It is a good question, and yes.
I mean that the short answer is yes and
no.
Could you put the question
right back up again?
So I can see it.
When we created this
conversation analysis tool.
We did it as simple as we could.
So that it would apply across disciplines.
And so, conversing is an important
skill across all disciplines.
So at the very basic level,
these three dimensions are going to
be applicable in any grade level,
in any content area.
But there is obviously going to
be difference in the qualitative
nature of the conversations depending on
your grade level and on your content area.
There's also gonna be great
differences and prompts.
But as far as good source for
good prompts, in different disciplines.
I think, and
Jeff may have more to add to this.
But in my opinion,
the most important source for
creating a good prompt is your content.
So it's, you can't just say that
these are some good prompts for
art or for environmental science.
Because you're prompt passage connecting
very very intimately to the content that
you're addressing.
There are ways to phrase questions.
So that they don't create
these one word answers, but
if your prompt doesn't connect intimately
to the content you're addressing.
Then it's not worth much anyway.
Do you guys wanna add anything to it?
>> One good example is that math
conversations are different from English
conversations.
And how are they different?
For example,
one way of engaging in maybe you'd it call
it supporting ideas in math is not by
referring to some example from the text.
But rather using mathematical reasoning
based on mathematical principles.
So you're actually not looking for,
well the teacher said this, or
I found this in this book.
You're actually looking for
a mathematical explanation based
on mathematical principles.
That's just one example
that might be different.
Whereas in English, you're looking for
evidence from let's say the story, or
in history might be looking at evidence
from a primary source document.
And as Sara said, sources for
good prompts, yeah you can look.
I mean I definitely encourage people
to look for good prompts, and look for
and in some cases there will be good
prompts in curriculum materials.
One in the area of essential questions for
a unit that's often a decent
place to start, and
that's kind of what Sara was saying too
is there's often this big question.
Well that's something that we want
kids to be able to talk about.
And so that would be another place at
least find what is the essential idea turn
that into a question.
And it's probably gonna be you
know fairly decent prompt overall.
>> And this question of good prompts,
I mean we're still doing research on it
right now because it's a hard question.
And so sometimes you'll think
of a prompt is great and
we'll think a prompt is great and
then it flops.
And so it's a little bit of trial and
error to see whether or
not a certain type of question
will lead to the conversation.
>> Thank you very much Jeff,
Sara and Kenji for
your time today and
everyone who joined us on the line.
Again, this webinar is presented
on behalf of their new course,
Effective Conversation In The Classroom.
Available through the Stanford Center for
Professional Development.
Class starts August 2nd.
It's available entirely online.
We hope you'll join us, and thanks again.
Have a great rest of your day.